hey everyone welcome to the heavy
spoilers show I'm your host definition
and he now locked into the channel where
we've been watching The Watchmen to
break down everything that you need to
know about the new season on HBO after
the events of episode 8 a lot of things
are up in the air including dr.
manhattan's body and right now the
Internet is just rife with speculation
on what will be happening in the finale
for the show throughout this video we're
just gonna be going over some of the
best fan theories pointing out the
things that you may have missed and
discussing what we think will happen in
episode 9 though a lot of these are just
theories there is evidence to back them
up so there could be heavy spoilers here
if we're right if you just want to go
into the final episode as blind as
possible then I highly suggest that you
turn off now but without the way if
you're still here thank you for clicking
the video now let's get into our
breakdown and what happens next to dr.
Manhattan okay so in my opinion the
first series of Watchmen has been an
absolutely crazy ride so far throughout
the episodes have aired we've had an
amazing amount of Revelations that are
really turned the Watchmen universe on
its head through X crimefighter well
Reeves we discovered that in Tulsa there
exists a white supremacist group who are
slowly hatching a plan to take over the
world led by Senator Joe Kean they've
devised a method in which they'll be
able to create their own version of dr.
Manhattan and used the Superman's
abilities to bring forth a new world
order
yikes the plan culminated in episode 8
in which we saw cavalry members arrive
at Angela Ava's house after it was
revealed that her husband Cal was
secretly dr. Manhattan it turns out that
Doc's been masquerading this entire time
as a regular man unbeknownst to everyone
other than Angela the final few shots of
the penultimate episode showed the doc
being zapped by a tachyon a cannon and
sent who knows where if the episode left
you scratching your head then don't
worry because we may have some answers
as to exactly what's going on before we
get into the theories though we just
kind of need to set up some establishing
information that actually adds a lot of
weight to what will be happening down
the line okay so if you've ever looked
into film analysis or just read up on
cool things that happen in movies you'll
often see that food plays a massive role
in TV shows and film Watchmen is no
different
and with a lot of seemingly unimportant
items comes hidden depth and subtext for
example in the original Watchmen graphic
novel Rorschach eats a can of beans and
thus when we see lookingglass doing it
in his own home it allows us to see that
the two have an almost shed psychology
both are pretty much in cells consider
their masks their real faces and don't
like to compromise on things in Episode
eight we also see a young John Osterman
aka dr. Manhattan pick up an apple from
the table in the castle which he then
drops upon seeing mr. Phillips and Miss
Cruikshank's having sex this holds more
importance later as the to confront John
about it and pass him a Bible pointing
out the picture of Adam and Eve Adam and
Eve lost their innocence over an apple
and thus when John drops it in the
episode upon seeing the two together it
mirrors the loss of innocence and
provides him with a new perception of
the world similar for the aforementioned
items eggs are prevalent throughout the
Watchmen TV series they pop up during
several scenes and even provide a
metaphor for episode 8 in which
characters discuss what came first the
chicken or the egg when trying to get
their head around how dr. Manhattan's
view of time works eggs and culture
represent birth springtime and because
of this they carry a lot of extra
meaning with them whether it's the
Easter Egg representing the birth of
Christ or even just your typical chicken
on a farm eggs have a symbolism that
comes with them that means they carry
new opportunities and possibilities it's
also said in the episode that an egg
potentially if embodied with dr.
Manhattan's powers could pass on his
abilities and off this theory ties
deeply into this ok so cast your mind
back to episode 2 of Watchmen in that we
see will pulling out boiling eggs from a
pot at the time this was kind of a weird
moment in the show and now knowing what
we do it's possible that this could be
highlighting exactly what's happened we
do know that will and dr. Manhattan
agreed to form an alliance at one point
and therefore there is a lot of
potential that the two are working
together in more ways than one will is
over a hundred years old and yet is
still quite a sprightly old fellow
especially for his age and he also seems
to have a vast knowledge of future
events coming eerily close to predicting
several things before they happen could
it be that the two actually formed an
alliance that goes beyond just me a
friend she
well the major theory at the moment that
is floating about the Internet is that
we'll actually already possesses or
carries the egg that allows him to take
on the powers of dr. Manhattan and he
either has or will consume it when the
right moment comes this is how he was
able to put his hand in boiling hot
water and go from being wheelchair-bound
to walking it also explains why dr.
Manhattan transports his and Angela's
kids directly to the character as you'll
be able to protect them I mean let's
face it if the seventh Cavalry does
succeed and Joe Keene becomes a doc
level being and it will take something
special to stop the children from coming
into harm's way
this explains why the doc felt that this
was the best place for them if will is
able to take on the powers then they
will be safe and yet it seems like a
pretty well thought-out plan will also
seems like the kind of person who
deserves the powers of a God as over his
100 year lifespan he has demonstrated
and need to do the right thing and even
in his old age he puts duty before death
could this be why John was also making
waffles in the kitchen I mean he did say
watch the eggs which Angela and smashed
so it looks like there was some
importance with them could Jonah
finished up the waffles while Angela was
outside fighting the cavalry and then
when to will with the means to pass on
his powers potentially and personally I
can definitely see this being the case
next week and who better to have on your
side failing that the powers could
easily pass over to Angela through the
pool that was a big plot point of the
latest episode in episode 8 Angela and
John fight it out beside the water with
the former saying that it's important
that Angela sees him there it is
possible that he could have passed on
his abilities into the water and if
Angela drinks from the pool and she too
could possess them this would be like a
Fountain of Youth metaphor and we
definitely know that there is some
importance to this scene there's also a
theory that John could have created back
up in the water as in the episode we do
see him using a body of liquid to create
clones it is possible that if Angela
returns there then she'll be able to
fish them out and potentially use them
to get John back this theory I'm kind of
unsure of as she doesn't really have the
means to grow them but as we saw with
Ozzy on Europa he was able to fish our
clones so there is potential that they
could be here now after the finale of
the episode you may be wondering where
John actually is well
we do know that he's not dead as before
being shot by the tachyonic cannon he
did say that it was going to transport
him
we know that the cavalry are capable of
teleportation so it is possible that
this moved him directly to the holding
cell that we saw them building in
episode 7 going off the preview of the
next episode we do actually see John
trapped and also Keene readying himself
to strip the docs powers however he
likely hasn't counted on looking glass'
being out and about and in episode 7 PT
did stumble across his bunker and a
bunch of dead cavalry members with one
missing a mask it seems likely that LG
is now wearing this and has infiltrated
the Cavalry's headquarters and is about
to stop the experiment from happening
from the thumbnail of the episode 9
promo trailer and clips from next week's
entry it looks like Laurie is being
guarded by a cavalry member I definitely
think that this will be looking-glass
and he could end up freeing her we know
the latter has been pining after dr.
Manhattan for a while and she would
definitely be up for saving him even if
it means teaming up with old mirror guy
personally though and animal owned on
this I do actually think that Keene will
gain the powers but in doing so realize
that all of the goals that he wished to
achieve are now meaningless to him I
mean imagine having the powers of dr.
Manhattan yeah running for president it
just kind of seems like a step down we
know that John himself doesn't really
wish to rule the world due to his
enlightenment so I can see Keene being
in a similar position however even with
his abilities he is still a danger and I
think the Millennium Clock is actually a
device that will destroy both Keene and
Manhattan he could also be a way to
activate sleeper cells in the country
that all possess the genes of Ozymandias
the character in the post-credits scene
of episode 8 mentions that he has 8
million children on earth and these
could provide true with an army in which
defy the cavalry width we know the
Millennium clock tells time but it could
also show the future to these people
directly letting them know what may
happen if they don't act well we don't
know for definite and that does seem
like a bit of a stretch however it looks
like the plans are slowly starting to
come together and honestly I can't wait
to see what happens I really hope we
don't end on a cliffhanger but yeah
if we do at least that gives us hope for
season two anyway it's been a blast
going through these theories with you
and hey if you're watching this video
after seeing the episode then I hope at
least one of them was right
whether you're dr. Manhattan and know
all of the answers or just a regular
person like me I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the episode and if you agree
with the theories in this video comment
below and let me know and yeah if you
enjoyed this please give me a thumbs up
as I massively appreciate it
also make sure you stay locked to the
channel for breakdowns of the finale
next week as it's gonna be so much to
talk about and I'd love to have you
there you also do a podcast called
watching The Watchmen in which we break
down the original graphic novel issue by
issue so if you want to know the full
backstory of the book then make sure you
check it out after this you want to come
chat to me after the video that make
sure you follow me on twitter at
definition whitey will head over to my
discord server which should be linked in
the description below we drop videos on
there early so if you want to see stuff
before anyone else and that's the best
place to be it's free to join and we
have an awesome community so hopefully I
see you over there very soon we're also
giving away a free copy of the marble
phase 3 part 2 boxer on blu-ray which
contains Black Panther infinity war and
Game Captain Marvel or more and all you
have to do to be in with a chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on the theories in the comment
section below
but when it's gonna be chosen on the
15th of December and the set will be
shipped out from then to ever get
surprised it's the best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thank you
for taking the time to watch this I've
been definition you've been the best
I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
[Music]